oh hey I'm Thomas Rhett
singer-songwriter and today celebrity
spokesman mr. hat which one would you
prefer let's see I'll take that one and
please call me TR let's talk about
hunger in America for a second did you
know that 42 million people struggle
with hunger that's one in eight of us
that's one date of our neighbors our
classmates 1 and 8 hard-working folks
just trying to make ends meet we need to
help and we can all you have to do is
look for specially marginal Mills
products with this handsome man it's go
about so yeah sure go hashtag outnumber
hunger y'all when you enter the code on
the box at outnumber hunger calm you
know feeding America secure five meals
on behalf of your local food bank and
you get a free Pandora plus trial
including access to an exclusive Pandora
mix tape featuring yours truly and my
friends a big machine like Reba Jennifer
Nettles Justin Moore and for Georgia
line making a difference never sounded
so good head to your local store look
for me on the box and help feed America
[Music]